j'ai encore fait un rêve bizarre la nuit
dernière c'était agréable où est-ce que
tu rêvais de moi j'ai rêvé d'un homme
pauvre message qui changeait la vie de
notre ville j'ai très bien vu son visage
merci beaucoup d'être venu les amis des
bêtes
j'ai un meeting au bureau avec des
acheteurs à 6h30 il faut que j'aille
déposer des contrats dallas pinard
partie tout ce que vous avez déjà eu des
problèmes de maladies infectieuses dans
le coin
la nouvelle est que si tu ne dis pas à
débit je le ferais on est marié depuis
19 ans et partage partage plus la même
vie au partage plus rien
tu peux t'en as tu fait un choix
il faut qu'on parle à cet homme c'est
lui c'est l'homme que j'ai fait dans mon
rêve
vous ça comme un as besoin de connecter
j'aimerais pourtant le connaître vous
allez voir votre femme et lui redonne
faute après vous vous rendriez vraiment
siens mais si vous pouviez être un peu
plus gentille que vous voulez mon ami il
va falloir que je réfléchisse à ça
d'où vous venez après l'amour de ma
famille lemaitre 20 mi-temps c'est une
petite cabane et qui sait rien gagner de
l'argent et même un peu de respect des
déshérités des sans abri près de chez
vous jette complètement fêlé ou youtube
servir de leurs mâts pour travailler il
ya des choses que vous devez savoir sera
j'ai fait beaucoup de mal ce n'est pas
une mauvaise personne et je suis
heureuse d'être du camp était très sexy
ce que tu as fait aujourd'hui sortir
avec un sans abri c'était comment
franchement c'est surprenant
il ya des choses que vous devez savoir
sur quoi elle était la seule personne
qui met mais assez pour ne pas laisser
tomber
je t'aime annie rey
[Musique]
que vous soyez riche que vous soyez
pauvres nous sommes tous les sens après
nous essayons tous de rentrer chez nous
denver a tout changé
nous n'aurions pas vécu ces moments
merveilleux
moi une bonne partie des autres membres
ça nous pose un problème que tu ramènes
ton peu pâle des gros ici tu peux lui
dire toi même il est juste derrière toi
[Musique]